[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
video is for all of you who saw the
brand new completely insane looking
faraday future ff91 at ces and wanted me
to compare it to tesla and make a little
video about it so that's what we're
about to do so first things first it's
their show car so this would be the one
that was on the floor at ces and it had
a lot going on there's a ton of people
walking around it drew lots of attention
at the booth and it looks just
absolutely sick the thing is an eiffel
whether you're a fan of the looks or not
it's definitely eye catching but so the
tail lights go all the way around the
back hatch and the headlights go all the
way around the front and it's just
really modern looking a silhouette kind
of seems like a stretched out tesla
model x like if you stretch one sideways
and added a bunch of new features to it
that's kind of what it reminded me of
still all electric still with the
battery pack in the bottom still with
the motors between the wheels but
there's a ridiculous amount of new
sensors and displays and just things
that they've added to it to be different
like there's a radar lidar blaster that
comes up from the front trunk which i
guess would make the trunk a little
smaller there a crazy looking array of
leds in the front grille and also on all
other places on the car
cameras instead of rear view mirrors and
even wireless charging with some led
indicators on the ground just crazy
futuristic stuff for an electric car but
this is all just a show car as much as
you want to talk about it and claim it's
your product uh it's ces this isn't a
working car and a lot of people love to
point that out but faraday future did
bring some working prototypes of the ff1
to ces this year a beta car 1 for the
self-driving and self-parking demo and a
beta car 2 for a little performance and
driving demonstrations and this is where
a lot of the comparisons to tesla came
into my mind when i went through these
it's obvious there's a lot of tesla in
the car's dna they have plenty of former
tesla employees at the company obviously
but they did some legitimate work to
make this different so for the
autonomous driving part yeah it had the
summon feature just like tesla but this
car actually apparently looked around a
parking lot for an empty spot and then
when it found one it backed into it
without touching any of the other cars
and the driver didn't have to touch the
pedal or the wheel during the whole
process which is really cool from the
passenger side and then for the
performance part
i don't know if you've seen the numbers
for this car but they're insane you know
130 kilowatt hour battery pack a
thousand plus horsepower 300 plus mile
range and a 0 to 60 mile per hour time
of a stupid fast
2.39 seconds which would make it the
quickest production car in the world if
it was in production but yeah i got to
demo that and i think the reaction kind
of speaks for itself all right so i can
pretty much guarantee is the fastest car
you've ever been in
um
yeah
yeah zero sixteen yeah zero sixty's
quickest for sure yeah yeah do some
sweepers here so you can feel that the
car really is very smooth graceful
uh feels really nice
nice and fluid
but we're gonna step it up a little bit
as i promised so we have active torque
vectoring and rear steering as you can
see the car really turns in nice wow so
it's very agile as soon as you turn the
wheel the driver has confidence that the
car is going to turn
now we do a lane change so i need you to
do someone needs to tell me now you
gotta tell me when to turn
all right you ready i'm ready okay tell
me now no
no
not bad right you guys ready for the big
event i'm ready a little bit of a launch
all right hold on seat heads all the way
against the seat rest you guys ready to
go
[Music]
that is legit not bad right that okay
now i need you to tell me something yeah
faster than your model s p 100 d cannot
confirm but probably yeah there we go
there we go i can because we've been
measuring it back to back 2.39 seconds
[Music]
so yeah there you have it the ff1 isn't
quite dead i know most people aren't
giving this thing a chance to exist and
that's understandable because this is so
damn new and obviously super ambitious
and it's been a rocky start for the
company already but looking at all the
new things and legitimately good ideas
they have i actually really want it to
happen the rear wheel steering for
example was something new it felt like a
really big deal when we did this driving
demo despite being a big car with a
really long wheelbase the rear wheel
assisting by turning up to 3.5 degrees
in addition to the front turning gives
this car like a super tight turning
radius so that lets you handle much
tighter corners and you can really feel
the difference in the car and then there
was just all sorts of other little stuff
like the the dual fins at the top of the
show car were said to be for dual radios
that would be used for the car's
connectivity i mean there's a ton of
tech packed in here probably a dozen
displays all around the car including
the inside and the outside
the rear view mirror cameras are
apparently supposed to be removable and
then can be replaced with standard
mirrors if you want or vice versa i mean
there's just so many good ideas the
wireless charging could be insane but it
just feels like the future so bottom
line i'm glad someone's trying you know
someone's gotta try and with tesla's
success it feels like the car industry
is finally taking that turn so why not
be super optimistic about it and a lot
of people are for this one cross your
fingers for this one folks thanks for
watching and i'll talk to you in the
next one peace
[Music]